the eh-2-zed of isms what about ISM what
about ISM also known as what about er II
is a way of criticizing and in some
people's minds defeating an opponent by
accusing them of hypocrisy what about X
what about Y as a political tactic it
was employed by the Nazis in the 1930s
when Nazi Germany was censored for an
xìng territories in Europe its officials
countered by saying that Germany was
only doing what countries like Britain
and France have been doing for centuries
in Africa and Asia the practice was
continued by the Soviet Union in the
1950s in the area of human rights
challenged on the murder of Soviet
citizens by the state Soviet officials
countered by saying that black people
were being lynched every day in the USA
the term water battery was also used in
the 1970s in Northern Ireland when
Republicans and loyalists pointed to
their own sufferings as a justification
for supporting violent action all these
instances are dramatic but ignore the
fact they're based on an invalid
argument the notion that two wrongs make
a right
what about ISM is not a useful or
logical form of debate but it relies on
the idea that two wrongs make a right
and while there is a lot of support for
this notion see also an eye for an eye
it's a false analogy doing a bad thing
cannot be excused by the existence of
another bad thing if I steal your car
you should tell the police stealing my
car is not an appropriate response also
it's generally just an excuse the Nazis
didn't invade Poland as a protest
against British imperialism the Soviets
didn't murder their own people as a
reaction to American racism you didn't
steal my car because I stole his car and
so on in the last few years
what about ISM has resurfaced partly
because it's easier to point fingers
away from yourself and at yourself
partly because the internet is not
always a place for high quality debate
and partly because there's always room
for one more idiot and the stupid car
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon